on an ordinary day in 1991 a Young Man
known by the initials JS went on a hike
with four of his friends on the wooded
outskirts of their small town everything
seemed perfectly normal until JS began
to feel a strange sense of familiarity
like he had been in this spot before he
couldn't shake this weird feeling but
thought nothing more of it little did he
know that this was a sign of deadly
things to come several hours after first
experiencing that sense of deja vu JS
was found by the side of the road
covered in cuts and scratches with his
friends nowhere to be found this is the
story of scp-939 an unforgettable
monster that you'll never remember
there was no way for JS to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the
horrors that followed it were the result
of an experiment conducted by the SCP
Foundation an experiment with deadly
unforeseen consequences
JS and his friends were exposed to a
substance known only as amn c227 as part
of a series of tests performed by the
SCP Foundation intended to determine the
effectiveness of this substance as a
deliberate and knee stick
dealing with as many mysterious secret
creatures and objects as they do the SCP
Foundation has long needed a way to
tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's various
prisoners and test subjects and when the
foundation discovered amn c227 it seemed
like it might be perfect for this
purpose so where did amnc227 come from
over a year before the incident with JS
and his friends the SCP Foundation
captured scp-939
scp-939 is a species of endothermic
predators that live and hunt in packs
their designated ketter class and
regarded as highly dangerous and hostile
to human life native to caves they have
no eyes translucent red skin and stand
at an average of 2.2 meters tall with an
average weight of 250 kilograms they
have four limbs each ending in three
fingered Claws and a fourth opposable
digit resembling a thumb
in addition to their sharp claws their
mouths are filled with red fang-like
teeth that reach up to six centimeters
in length in place of their absent eyes
they have light sensitive spots running
along their backs
which are covered in spines believed to
detect changes in air pressure and flow
in addition to their many other
terrifying attributes the internal
anatomy of scp-939 poses a biological
mystery these creatures have no
circulatory system and no digestive
tract that's right in spite of being
Predators seemingly acting on a need to
feed they have no stomach instead when
they eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function and then it is
regurgitated in spite of being a
creature that should not under any
logical conditions be able to live
scp-939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the SCP Foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in September of 1992 though
the creatures remain just as much of a
scientific mystery as they were upon
first discovery
everything about them seems to defy the
logic of the natural world which to be
fair is really nothing new for the
foundation the respiratory system of
scp-939 was found to Exhale small traces
of an airborne amnestic substance given
the name amn c227 this compound blocks
the formation of memories for the
duration of exposure to it plus a
30-minute period following the exposure
give or take a few minutes it is
colorless odorless tasteless and
completely undetectable in the
bloodstream after only 60 Minutes amn
c227 was approved for use as a Class C
amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990
following some initial tests however
after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends the official
use of amn c227 was suspended JS and
three of his four friends were
previously given a dose of amn c227
though the details of why they were
given the amnestic has since been
stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amnc227 JS and his friends went out on
their ill-fated hiking trip while hiking
JS was suddenly overcome with the sense
of deja vu when he mentioned it to his
friends three of them agreed that they
had felt it too one of the group another
young man who had not been exposed to
amnc 227 was uncomfortable and decided
to go home
JS and the remaining three members of
the group made the choice to stay in the
woods and try to determine what was
triggering the unusual feeling of
familiarity as they got closer and
closer to a large cave near the hiking
trail the sense of having been there
before grew stronger and stronger
armed with only one flashlight and a
foolish curiosity the four went inside
the cave
they made their way deeper and deeper
and deeper into the darkness not knowing
why they felt this way or what they
might find inside none of the group
could explain just what felt so familiar
only that the further they made their
way into the cave the more pronounced
the feeling became it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source and no
knowledge of what lay inside but still
they pressed on one of the group
remarked that they should turn back but
the others refused to listen they wanted
to know what they were getting close to
what was drawing them deeper and deeper
into the cave unfortunately for them
they would get their answer in the heart
of the cave was a pack of scp-939
waiting patiently for their prey to
wander into their domain there are no
witnesses to account for what exactly
happened to JS and his companions but we
can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after once the
friends reached the heart of the Cave
the creatures were on them in seconds
raking them with their sharp claws and
biting with their
scp-939 are larger and stronger than
most people so it was probably not much
of a fight however while his friends
were being devoured JS was somehow able
to scramble out of the cave and make his
way into the woods in search of help
under the influence of the AMC 227 that
had built up in the cave from the
presence of the pack of scp-939 JS lost
a large portion of his memory of the
event he found himself on the side of
the highway late at night seriously
injured and his clothes ripped an
officer found him there and asked him to
stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive JS was still in a
panic and attempted to run away from the
officer begging to be released so that
he could get away he babbled
incoherently about the color red
screaming over and over again about the
red though when prompted he could not
explain what the red he was screaming
about referred to his friends were not
with him just as the officer managed to
calm JS the ambulance arrived its
flashing red lights sent him into
another frenzy and he attempted to
escape custody claiming that the red
lights were going to get him the
official police report described JS as
perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen that he was just
having a bad trip but the SCP Foundation
knew better
the foundation conducted an interview
with JS about his experience and
determined that scp-939 was certainly
involved as part of their cover-up
effort they strongly implicated JS in
The Disappearance and the death of his
friends he was convicted of manslaughter
though the bodies of his friends were
never found it is rumored that the SCP
Foundation hired him on a prison work
release program and that he now works as
a member of the janitorial staff at one
of the foundations facilities
this incident led to the suspension of
the use of amn c227 as it revealed some
vital and disturbing information about
the compound side effects after the
exposure to amn c227 a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would
experience a sense of familiarity and
felt compelled to investigate the source
of this feeling essentially anyone
treated with amn c227 are not made aware
of the existence and danger of scp-939
would become a perfect victim primed to
be attracted to dens of scp-939 it is
likely that this side effect is not a
coincidence but rather a deliberate
hunting tactic designed to attract prey
that had somehow managed to escape with
no memory of their attack at the hands
of scp-939 this previous intended prey
would find themselves drawn to the same
Den or even a new one not knowing that
they were walking back into near certain
death while the SCP Foundation suspended
the use of amnc227 as a Class C amnestic
they did recruit a team of SC P field
operatives to take advantage of this
side effect this team of operatives were
deliberately administered a dose of
amnc227 and briefed on its effects as
well as the dangers of following the
feeling of deja vu should its surface in
the field these infected officers were
essentially used as Bloodhounds relying
on any sense of unusual familiarity to
sniff out new dens of scp-939 so they
could be captured and contained by the
foundation
as far as we know this operation is
still ongoing today however now that the
foundation has a sufficient number of
specimens to study additional dens of
scp-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed as for the
scp-939 still in captivity they are
contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressured cells with
walls of reinforced concrete the doors
to the cells are airtight to prevent the
leakage of any amn c227 and any
Personnel that interact with one of the
creatures is required to wear level C
Hazmat gear to avoid exposure and follow
decontamination procedures upon exiting
the cell all scp-939 have subdermal
tracking devices implanted to find them
in the event of Escape
only one scp-939 has given birth in the
time that the creatures have been in
captivity strangely
scp-939 young look indistinguishable
from Human infants and change their
physical appearance at some yet unknown
Point as they age if any more offspring
are produced they will immediately be
separated from the parent and studied
all that we know is that they are found
in caves in the woods outside of a small
town it it could be any town even yours
so if you're ever out hiking and struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu
don't investigate don't get curious
just go home
it might just save your life the fabric
of our world is littered with strange
doorways if you know where to look for
them tares portals anomalies all leading
to places and planes Beyond human
imagining and understanding an scp-2317
otherwise known as a door to another
world certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed but of course
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed doorway isn't where it
leads it's what it keeps out
even by the foundation's already high
standards the requirements and
regulations for personnel who are
assigned to scp-2317 seem oddly specific
psychological testing is standard
practice to work for the foundation but
an additional hurdle that anyone has to
clear before even getting to Glimpse at
this unassuming wooden door is having a
score of at least 72 on the Milgram
obedience examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if
scp-2317 is a door to another world an
alternate Dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit after
all the foundation has been sending
Personnel in there on a regular basis
daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of something lurking
beyond that old wooden door frame
but what could possibly warn such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months
and spend the following third month in
full psychological counseling before
they are permitted to return to the
containment unit housing the door to
another world
was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however he wanted to
know what had happened to the last guard
that had performed the procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security personnel
the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edge knife a silver
asparagulum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely event of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317
every member of Staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a Barren salt plane
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady Pace as
he stepped counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals Seven Rings seven Thrones
for the Scarlet King he said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
he knew it wasn't his place to question
the foundation as the 220 Calabasas
procedure took place the guard couldn't
help but wonder what all this was for it
seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of science
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and obese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds and its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom
it knows as well as the foundation that
nothing can be done to prevent the final
chain from one day breaking
even procedure 220 Calabasas won't keep
the creature contained
it's nothing more than a smoke screen an
act designed to create an illusion of
active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent
solution can be devised to keep
scp-2317 imprisoned
of course if the guard had known this it
would have also explained the need for a
one kiloton nuclear device as part of
this stage ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious and
occult rituals The increased level of
security surrounding the procedure and
its purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if you had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane
the entire Dimension was calm silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day
the door was closed behind the guard as
he the celebrant the assistant and his
fellow security officers stepped back
through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed as such the o5
council has elected to continue
providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that procedure 220
Calabasas is an effective strategy for
containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed
at least for a little while longer
SCP-173 it's one of the most iconic
anomalies ever contained by the SCP
Foundation this next snapping site-19
celebrity is known and feared by
everyone who works at the foundation
since being contained in 1993. its nubby
concrete hands metaphorically and quite
literally stained with the blood of
countless people but this mostly
immobile Oddity wasn't always a resident
of site 19 and the story of how exactly
it ended up there and more importantly
why is far more ridiculous insane and
downright terrifying than you could ever
imagine so buckle up SCP fans this is
the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of Modern Art ended up at the SCP
foundation's largest containment site to
give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is we're gonna have to leap
forward to the year of 2045. we know
what you're thinking isn't this a
prequel how can it take place in the
future sit tight folks it'll all make
sense in the end site 91 is where we lay
our scene under the watchful eyes of
site director Dr James long a senior
researcher with level 4 security
clearance the second highest at the
foundation Dr long had given Decades of
devotion and his expertise to the
foundation he was a proud man who wore
his life of service to the containment
cause as a badge of honor after years of
dodging death while researching some of
the most dangerous anomalies that
site-91 had to offer he had ascended to
the rank of site director which
represented the culmination of his
life's work and in his new position of
power he'd only proved himself further
running a tight ship and reducing the
number of containment breaches across
the board nobody could say that Dr long
was an extremely talented at his job
which is why he was so confused when he
received an email from Alexandra Nala an
administrative assistant working
directly for the o5 council it was the
type of email that no site director ever
wanted to receive Dr long was being told
back to with no input or oversight from
him the majority of site-91's anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed
location for safer containment the list
contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site including
of course
SCP-173 this particular anomaly had been
contained at the site for 37 years after
being delivered there in 2008. Dr long
had devised a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time
creating a sprinkler system within the
chamber that washes away the waste
products produced by 173 reducing the
need for risky human contact but that
didn't matter despite Dr Long's loyalty
and efficacy in serving the SCP
Foundation the decision had already been
made with no chance of reversing it
according to Nala the motion to remove
most of site-91's anomalies had received
unanimous approval from the o5 council
and the operations for the transfer
would be commandeered by the department
of extra Universal Affairs headed by
senior agent Sven Kish Dr long was both
upset and confused he was producing some
of the best results across the entire
foundation so why were they taking away
all of his anomalies did someone on the
yo 5 Council have it out for him Dr Long
replied to Nala asking if considering
how severe the relocation operation was
going to be whether he could get more
information on where the anomalies were
being moved to and why he felt that at
the very least he was owed some answers
on this Nala and her superiors didn't
feel quite the same way she replied that
Dr Long sadly didn't have the clearance
to know any of the operations
particulars this information was
reserved for those with level 5
clearance and members of the
multi-universal department all that Dr
Long needed to do was stay out of the
way and everything would be taken care
of for him but that wasn't enough for Dr
long he needed to know more he needed to
understand why this seemingly random
decision had been made realizing that
Nala and mv05 Council were a dead end as
far as information was concerned he
instead reached out to the next best
thing senior agents Fen Kish the member
of the Department of extra Universal
Affairs who was spearheading the
relocation Mission Dr Long implored the
agent to give him extra information on
where all the site-91 anomalies were
being moved and why they were being
moved in the first place predictably he
was once again stonewalled being told
that any information regarding the
project was above his level of clearance
in a move that seemed decidedly spiteful
agent Kish signed off by saying that he
looked forward to seeing Dr Long at site
91 and not long after that he did agent
Kish along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the multi-u
Department arrived on site bearing
state-of-the-art containment equipment
an exasperated Dr Long wasn't able to
glean any more information from this
experience the multi-u agents were
ruthlessly efficient transferring The
Lion's Share of the anomalies into
temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours by the
time they were done Dr long and his
staff were left with one of the most
desolate and empty containment sites on
the foundation's books here was Dr long
with Decades of service and climbing the
organizational ladder only to be left as
a glorified babysitter for a handful of
low priority anomalous items it all felt
like a cruel joke after several days of
nothing happening in the now incredibly
uneventful site-91 a board Dr Long
reached out to a friend of his
researcher narul shafiqe binte Ahmad
Ibrahim whom he called by the nickname
Shack to vent his frustrations she
commiserated sharing her sympathy for
his suddenly much less exciting working
conditions but saying that at least the
job should be a little less lethal now
Shaq didn't know it yet but on this
particular Point she was terribly wrong
Dr Long shared his theory that perhaps
some sites were being Consolidated so
the foundation could save money and that
this would lead to layoffs Shaq
essentially told him that he was
worrying too much the reality was that
Dr long had some very good reasons to be
worried his problem was that he hadn't
been worrying about the right things in
Foundation containment area 179
something awful was brewing as usual
guards posted around
scp-2317 an old door containing a portal
to another world waited while Foundation
staff and d-classes performed the
standard procedure 220 Calabasas ritual
within they were dealing with one of the
most dangerous anomalies in the entire
universe but even then after Decades of
service one can be numb to such things
suddenly without warning the door opened
and a terrified Foundation researcher
tumbled out panting heavily eyes bulging
in existential horror he screamed the
words that he long hoped would never be
spoken in his or even his children's
lifetime it happened the chains have
broken the Devourer is free the sirens
sounded and alert spread across the
entire Foundation database
scp-2317 is compromised
scp-2317-k the Devourer of Worlds is
free if the creature escapes area 179 an
XK Class end of the world scenario is
basically assured so all efforts will be
taken to make sure that the creature
does not Escape at any cost and they
really did mean any cost the old wooden
door of scp-2317 splintered as an
immense scaly hand sprang forth and
caught a wave of Devastation throughout
the containment chamber guards were
dispatched in the hundreds with heavy
Weaponry to buy some time firing at the
Devourer a beast the size of a mountain
Rose from the ground staring at the
terrified humans below with its one
gigantic red eye it couldn't even feel
the bullets explosives or incendiary and
Laser Weaponry being used on it the
monster just Shrugged it off and
murdered nearly all of its attackers
with one swipe of its claw in a final
desperate act hoping to kill or at least
slow down the Beast staff at area 179
made the ultimate sacrifice and
detonated the entire on-site nuclear
Arsenal the explosion disintegrated the
entire facility in an instant and
Unleashed a radioactive shock wave that
carried Destruction for miles but it
wasn't enough
scp-2317-k walked out of the mushroom
cloud without a scratch on it ready to
show the human world what real
destruction meant at this point the
battle was already effectively lost but
the foundation refused to go down
without a fight they dispatched all
available mobile task forces including
mobile Task Force new 7 Hammer town a
heavily armed Battalion strength task
force created to combat the biggest and
most extensive threats imaginable and it
wasn't even just the foundation true
existential threats have a way of
uniting people as the GOC and even the
chaos Insurgency temporarily put aside
their differences to take the fight to
the Devourer but would any of it be
enough barrages of cruise missiles and
icbms did nothing to Halt the devourer's
assault as it rampaged destroying towns
and cities at first then regions then
whole Nations swarms of scrambled Jets
and helicopters were knocked out of the
sky with casual swipes the creature
bulldozed over Landscapes teeming with
tanks and heavy artillery Vehicles it
snapped aircraft carriers in half as it
waited from Ocean to Ocean
systematically destroying everything in
its path even satellite-mounted orbital
cannons and the heavy energy weapons of
MTF tau5 also known as samsara did
nothing to phase the Devourer it was
finally coming to fruition the dreaded
XK Class end of the world scenario and
none of the foundation's expertise
advanced technology or Limitless
resources could do anything to stop it
they aided in evacuation efforts getting
as many people as they could out of
Harm's Way as the Devourer rampaged and
destroyed but even that was doing little
more than borrowing time eventually the
Devourer would destroy all of them there
would be nothing left and all Dr James
long could do was watch helplessly from
an almost empty site-91 waiting for the
tide of Destruction to reach him of
course other Foundation employees most
prominently senior agent Sven Kish and
the multi-u department had other
concerns all they needed to do was
archive data for extraction extraction
to where you ask seeing as the world
seems to be at its end here while
Universe 7392 Epsilon blue Lima
otherwise known as our universe Circa
1993 the foundation Works across the
Multiverse and an XK class under the
world scenario in one Universe really
isn't necessarily a problem in others on
orders of the o5 council agent Kish and
his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from
doomed universes o5 knew that Dr Long's
Universe Universe 5643 gamma orange
Delta was due for an apocalyptic visit
from the Devourer of Worlds any day now
that's why the multi-u team went in to
extract everything worth Saving Dr long
and the millions of other level 4 and
Below employees of that universe's
Foundation were never told of their
impending deal after all that sort of
thing could probably lead to unnecessary
stress and what they don't know won't
hurt them until of course it does in
1993 these anomalous doomed Universe
scps were divided amongst our universe's
various applicable containment sites
SCP-173 as you already know ended up in
site 19 but sadly for the people working
there all the actual data files on this
entries file Were Lost in Translation so
as far as they knew 173 was little more
than a big weird statue with apparently
dangerous properties upon first placing
it in its containment chamber in site-19
Euclid Wing Foundation Legend Dr bright
unaware of just what he had here
assigned Dr William Moto to begin
research on the entity he recommended
that the researcher bring two d-classes
for testing when Dr Moto was faced with
the anomalous entity's blank file he
gave a sign began to write something in
its description box moved to site 19
1993 origin is as of yet unknown wasn't
that a delightful little tale now we
know how SCP-173 made its way into site
19 and what our own universe may have to
look forward to in 2045 so remember if
you ever see agent Sven Kish planning a
transfer of anomalies out of your site
maybe consider using some of that PTO
and maybe consider Putting a down
payment on a nice cozy apocalypse bunker
over in Iceland Jay and Michael were a
pair of urban exploration YouTubers
looking for their big break you might
remember their video exploring the dead
mall on the outskirts of your town or
the supposedly haunted 1950s insane
asylum out in the sticks but you
certainly won't find these videos
anywhere are online after the incident
at scp-823 all of their content was
scrubbed away from even the most
comprehensive internet archives why you
ask because these unfortunate Urban
explorers decided that their big break
would be exploring a certain abandoned
theme park and it would be one of the
last decisions they ever made Michael
and Jay had heard rumors about the theme
park its name was lost to time as was
the date of its opening and closing and
the reason it was even abandoned in the
first place even some of the most
hardcore Urban explorers didn't dare To
Tread there something about it a good
friend had once told Jay just didn't
feel right sometimes if you dared to
venture into the forest near the theme
park at night you can still hear music
the Jolly piping tunes of rides and
Carnival stands still beckoning as if to
say we're still here come and play of
course none of this frightened Jay in my
they could always smell the sponsorships
from headlamp and compact camera
companies no amount of anxiety would
stop them from making their Doom trip to
the so-called Carnival of Horrors it's a
terrible shame if they'd listen to the
stories of this place about how
unnatural and evil it could be they
might still be alive today like all the
best Urban explorers they arrived at the
woods near the abandoned theme park in
the dead of night they ignored the signs
warning them about everything from
structural instability to dangerous wild
animals to asbestos nothing would keep
them out nothing they reached the
abandoned theme park not long after
though it was a mere shell of its former
self during the several decades of
Abandonment nature had reclaimed it the
ferris wheel was covered in overgrown
Ivy and the carnival stands were
blanketed with mold as the duo swept
through the grounds with their
flashlights and cameras they saw a faded
sign that bore the words Thriller chill
Park's most popular roller coaster they
also took their time to Marvel at the
exceptionally creepy looking Tunnel of
Love the broken down house of mirrors
and a huge grinning statue of the Park's
former mascot happy hippo this theme
park was something out of a nightmare
which naturally made it potential video
gold but as the excited Duo wandered
further into the park they couldn't help
but notice the quiet tinny carnival
music music that seemed to be drawing
them closer Michael asked Jay if he
could hear the strange Impossible music
and felt a chill creep in when he
answered that he did could all the
stories be true they were lost in
thought but their legs kept moving they
were getting closer to something now
they could feel a presence and was that
music getting louder an instant later
though another sound cut through the
silence bang bang it echoed out through
the still night air birds flew from
their perches in the trees Jay and
Michael both fell to the ground dead
their heads taken off by the 50 caliber
rounds of a highly trained mobile task
force sniper on the payroll of the SCP
Foundation their recording equipment
along with their bodies were taken and
destroyed any trace of them were
scrubbed from the internet it may seem a
little harsh but a bullet to the head is
much Kinder fade than what would have
awaited these two if they'd kept walking
that's because the carnival of Horrors
is no dark fairy tale the rumors are all
true and something really is waiting in
the dark that's why this abandoned theme
park is known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-823 a euclid-class anomaly with a
violent history what's even more
unnerving is that the researchers
studying 823 have repeatedly implored
the o5 council to increase the Park's
classification to katir and allocate
more resources for containment only to
be denied but after you've heard about
the horrors that unfolded there and the
danger it poses you'll probably take the
researcher's side the park is divided
into two two zones the yellow zone and
the Red Zone there are to be at least
six members of foundation Personnel
present in the yellow zone at all times
to ensure that no civilians wander in
our two Urban explorers earn themselves
a death sentence not just by wandering
into the yellow zone but passing
dangerously close to the Red Zone this
is the true epicenter of the Park's
dangerous anomalous activity it's a
place so hazardous that anyone entering
whether they're a civilian or a member
of foundation staff is to be executed at
a distance by sniper fire without
hesitation once upon a time though
nobody knows exactly when there was a
theme park that seemed no different to
any other eager children and
thrill-seeking teens arrived by the
busload ready to stuff their faces with
cotton candy and corn dogs and then
reverse the process on a vast array of
roller coasters but even then during
these Good Times there was something
dark lurking behind the cheerful facade
little by little everyone visitors and
employees alike started falling victim
to strange and horrific accidents around
the park of course when it comes to
theme parks accidents come with the
territory but none like this here are
just a handful of the horrific and
mysterious deaths that occurred while
the park was open so strap in because
just like a roller coaster this isn't
for the faint of heart a pair of young
lovebirds decided they wanted to enjoy
the Romance of the tunnel of love the
two sad in a swan shaped boat as they
were ferried through darkened
passageways anyone would assume that
they were having a great time but at
some point terrible shrieks of pain and
fear began to echo through the ride
attendance confused and terrified
stopped the ride and found that the
screaming persisted just some stupid
teens playing a prank they figured and
started the ride again but when the swan
shaped boat finally exited the tunnel of
love the park employees were greeted to
a horrifying side the two teens dead
their bodies somehow fused together at
multiple points another unlucky customer
met a gruesome fade inside the house of
mirrors they entered but while inside
they were stalked by a mysterious
carnivorous humanoid entity known as
subject 79 the customer was pursued and
eventually caught by subject 79 and
brutally dismembered some parts of the
body were fused to the house of Mirror's
interior While others like the right arm
were never found the customer actually
survived their ordeal and whether that's
a happy ending is up to you but it
wasn't just the customers at the park
who were in danger a 23 year old Park
employee working a summer job collapsed
while entertaining children dressed as
the Park's cheerful mascot happy hippo
it wasn't uncommon for people to get
overheated and collapse in the heavy
suits on hot days but one thing was
different here he was screaming crying
and trying desperately to remove his
mask people rushed to help but nobody
could get the suit off and it was
declared dead soon after when he was
eventually cut out of the suit coroners
found that the employee had choked to
death his mouth trachea and lungs were
filled with a fibrous substance later
determined to be identical to the
stuffing of his costume an intense
roller coaster known as the Thriller
Chiller was a magnet for horrific
accidents which became more violent and
intense over time the first accident
seemed like a typical theme park tragedy
a safety harness failed dropping a rider
15 feet during an inverted Loop they
landed on the track below breaking their
neck and skull causing instant death
while this was a tragedy it wasn't
exactly anomalous but the next major
accident on the ride was an entirely
different story this time 15 people met
with disaster while riding the Thriller
Chiller roller coaster starting from the
front and moving back one car at a time
each group of riders was decapitated by
blunt force trauma a new pair of
decapitations appeared to happen at
every turn and loop on the Rhine
forensic scientists still have no idea
how this could have possibly occurred
despite all of these disasters the park
was only finally abandoned after a day
known as Bloody Sunday when the
anomalous powers of the location reached
a 20-year Peak it's believed that 231
people were killed during the Carnage of
that day and another seven were horribly
maimed the SCP Foundation contained the
carnival of Horrors not long after but
the mysterious deaths didn't even end
there Foundation mobile task force row
71 also known as the origami toads were
sent into assess containment procedures
and discover the source of all the
anomalous deaths they were unsuccessful
though and instead they merely added to
the list in exceptionally horrifying
ways One agent was found dead surrounded
by empty grenades and bullet casings it
appeared he'd remove the explosive
propellant from all of his ballistics
and consumed it dying in the process
another was found with his jaw broken
having apparently pulled out and inhaled
his own teeth and dying of the resulting
internal damage the commander got the
worst fate of all so horrifying in fact
that we can't tell you the full details
all you need to know is that something
was shoved into his brain that that
really didn't belong there the
foundation considered having the entire
park destroyed with a massive air strike
courtesy of the mobile Task Force new 7
AKA Hammer Town however the o5 council
denied this request on the basis that
the park was too close to populated land
they'd have no plausible cover story for
the bombing and they don't even really
know if blowing up the park would
prevent anomalous activity from
occurring the carnival of Horrors is
here to stay folks the foundation just
hopes to keep it from getting new
visitors so then back to why the
researchers want this place upgraded to
ketir after all these classifications
aren't about how dangerous an anomaly is
they're about how difficult and
complicated they are to contain but
here's the problem according to the
researchers the Red Zone where the
dangerous anomalous activity is at its
peak is inbound to one fixed position
its change position at least three times
already and even worse it appears to be
growing not seemingly so Euclid class
now is it after all you might not even
need to visit the carnival of Horrors to
be in grave danger if it keeps growing
then someday soon the carnival of
Horrors may be visiting you SCP
Foundation agent stationed at area 37
had intercepted chatter from a normally
closed communication system in a nearby
City to anyone else the calls that the
foundation were eavesdropping would seem
innocent even boring but the foundation
immediately recognized the coded
language being used they were listening
to Communications between underground
cells of the Serpent's hand a dangerous
paramilitary organization that stands in
opposition to everything the foundation
is trying to do once deciphered the
Serpent's hand messages revealed plans
for killing Foundation Personnel
breaking into containment sites and
releasing anomalous creatures and
objects into the world pretty standard
stuff for the foundation's least
favorite anomaly loving insurgents but
they kept using one code that even the
foundation didn't have any intel on they
kept asking about the condition of the
sisters Fate has a funny way of sneaking
up on you though and in time they would
know more about the powerful sadistic
reality warping beings known as the
sisters than they could have possibly
imagined but what they would eventually
learn was not the kind of data that
anyone would ever want to have after
intercepting clear lines of
communication from a local Serpent's
hand cell triangulating the location of
their compound was Child's Play and
mobile task forces were dispatched from
area 37 with orders to neutralize the
Potential Threat before they could mount
an attack on a facility just when the
Serpent's hands least expected it they
had heavily armed Foundation soldiers
kicking down their doors crashing
through windows and rappelling down from
the ceiling as expected the Serpent's
hand put up a fight but thanks to their
Superior training and the element of
surprise the foundation's mobile task
for is came out on top they were able to
capture 15 members of the group for
interrogation as well as a collection of
anomalous objects being stored by the
group among them were a small wooden
Loom an enamel needle and a glass eye
when the task force obtained these
seemingly mundane items a haunted
looking Serpent's hand began laughing
wildly he kept repeating you have no
idea what you're getting yourselves into
nobody knew just how right this man was
not yet anyway congratulating themselves
on a job well done the mobile task
forces hauled their captives and the new
anomalous items back to area 37 a
heavily isolated Foundation site that
specializes in the early containment of
anomalous objects for initial
observation and study the objects hadn't
displayed any anomalous properties in
transit maybe the Serpent's hand was
lying and these weren't dangerous items
at all or it was actually just a pile of
junk either way they were sent to a
foundation researcher on site to conduct
preliminary tests the loom the needle
and the glass eye were laid out across
the table for observation when suddenly
the attending researcher felt a dark
presence looming behind him he turned
with sweat beating on his brow and saw
three humanoid translucent figures
floating in the air behind him they
would soon become known as
scp-1765 1 2 and 3. the researcher could
feel the power emanating from these
Silhouettes reality seemed to bend and
Shimmer around them the way heat
distorts the air into a mirage he could
tell right away that they were powerful
reality warpers even in their brief time
communicating with the researcher one
two and three displayed both
intelligence and unique personalities
one was clearly the ringleader
displaying an articulate command of
language two displayed a more
mischievous side speaking with a cockney
accent and had a tendency towards creepy
giggling three was the least
communicative of them all preferring to
speak in short simple sentences often
consisting of just single words though
of course actions speak far louder than
words and it didn't take long for the
Sisters to Define themselves with their
actions one told the scared and confused
researcher that they'd been observing
the SCP Foundation for quite some time
and that they deeply admired the
foundation's adherence to the scientific
method of course the researcher wasn't
so much flattered by the sister's
statement as they were afraid for their
life they tried to call security for
backup but found that their tongue was
withering and turning into a shriveled
blackened Husk in their mouth the
sisters didn't like to be interrupted as
the tongueless researchers slowly
collapsed in front of them the sisters
explained the purpose of their visit
they wish to assist the foundation in
their quest for knowledge and as such
they would conduct a number of
experiments on their behalf they would
then happily share the resulting data
with the foundation to compare Notes One
expressed optimism saying that she
believed they were about to embark on a
beautiful scientific relationship the
reality couldn't be further from the
truth the sisters began their work
moving rapidly around the facility
bending and twisting reality wherever
they went they circled area 37 making it
separate from the rest of the world it
inhabited area 37 no longer belonged to
planet Earth it belonged to the sisters
it was their private experimentation lab
filled with live and unwilling guinea
pigs the foundation attempted to retake
the facility by force sending in Mobile
task force Iota 6 also known as the
canvas cats into the belly of the beast
but they never returned in addition to
changing the fabric of reality itself
they also altered the physical structure
of area 37 to better serve their
experimental designs it was divided into
four sections marked a b c and d each
with their own unique purpose section A
which had formerly been area 37 store
keeping mess hall and dormitories had
been the least affected by the sister's
attacks on reality the biggest
alterations were the appearance of two
large metal Vats situated in the east
corner of the mess hall a monitoring
station connected to the other sections
of area 37 that replaced the store
keeping zones and an imposing marble
sign hanging above the dormitories that
reads control group a quick refresher
from science class the control group in
an experiment is the group that isn't
subjected to the experimental effects
the others are so they can be used as a
benchmark to measure against the same
was true here the prisoners in the
control group were the safest of all but
they were forced to do something almost
as bad they had to watch the horrors
playing across the rest of the facility
one of the sisters would occasionally
return to this section to oversee the
feeding of the control subjects and to
encourage them to take part in the
observation of their unlucky peer
section B which had formerly been area
37's outer grounds and sports facilities
had been transformed into the center of
a localized spatial temporal abnormality
in layman's terms this meant that its
size climate atmospheric conditions
pressure and temporal flow were all
subject to constant changes based on the
whims of sister number one who oversaw
all the experiments performed in section
B for those unfortunate enough to be
trapped in sector B
scp-17651 was their God but she didn't
subject them to her whims randomly no in
her own words the purpose of section B
was to delve into the effects of
repetitive action performed under
unusual conditions on the human psyche
for example one experiment was set up to
test the physical and mental fortitude
of a researcher a field agent and a
sanitation worker the trio were confined
in the Sports Center in order to measure
the length of every single pipe and the
angle at which each connected to others
with nothing more than a wrench a ruler
a brown paper pad and a ballpoint pen
the task was an arduous one taking over
10 hours and as soon as the subjects
were done one restructured the sports
center and ordered them to perform the
task again the same happened another 459
times before one finally concluded the
experiment leaving the subjects with
broken bodies and Minds in the aftermath
section c which had previously been the
facility's main office block exhibited a
similar level of anomalous activity to
section B except that it was the domain
of the more sadistic and mischievous
sister number two her main area of
scientific interest was studying group
dynamics and interpersonal relationships
during extreme conditions very extreme
conditions for one experiment the office
block had been transformed into a kind
of football stadium with the goal posts
removed and replaced by concrete bunkers
the two teams were the captured serpent
hand members and the members of MTF iota
6. Fresh Off Their attempt to retake the
sign the two groups were forced into a
deadly game with incomprehensible rules
including Rising platforms and hooded
figures throwing fiery projectiles into
the crowd trying to incinerate the
players but Victory didn't lead to
safety as the winners of the game were
crushed to death with giant metal
hammers just for the fun of it two
didn't even try to pretend that this act
had a valid scientific justification
section D which had once been the
facility's high-risk containment area
was now the strangest and most
mysterious section of all under the
charge of the equally peculiar and
enigmatic sister number three this area
appeared physically Unchained from its
state prior to the arrival of the
sisters temporally however section D was
the most warped of them all it existed
in the kind of temporal bubble outside
of the rest of our realities timeline
giving three a frightening amount of
control over all that went on in her
domain outside side of time there she
was performing the most strange and
incomprehensible experiment of all the
subject was the former site director at
area 37 he was brought to a table and
asked to choose between two different
flavors of ice cream that were presented
to him sounds simple enough so then why
is this the worst of all because the
site director is caught in a Time Loop
he's been choosing between various
flavors of ice cream for over 10 000
hours and he doesn't even seem to know
three's only comment on the matter
delicious all attempts to liberate the
unfortunate inhabitants of area 37 have
failed miserably the sisters don't
appear to operate on any form of logic
or empathy and thus cannot be reasoned
with with talks having failed in Mobile
task force Iota 6's attempt to retake
the site ending in disaster the only
solution left was to create a guarded
perimeter around the area using
technology like the Scranton reality
anchor to fight back against any
potential Escape by the sisters this
sisters are potentially so dangerous
that if they ever truly set their minds
to leaving it's considered acceptable to
detonate the facility's on-site nuclear
warhead in hopes of finally putting a
stop to them in the meantime the
foundation has built giant external
servers for processing the vast
quantities of research data the sisters
are constantly sending from their
horrifying experiments sadly for the
inhabitants of area 37 their Grim fate
continues to this day the experiments
never stop and the subjects have said
experiments seem to be condemned to the
eternal torment of
scp-1765 in a way their unwilling
sacrifice protects us all because if
ever the sisters were interested in
performing experiments on a larger
sample size well all we can do is hope
we end up in the control group
it's a perfect day for a wedding on a
warm spring afternoon a bride in a
handsome groom are exchanging the
special Rings they had system designed
and made for each other as they take
turns placing the rings on each other's
fingers a man standing at the end of the
wedding party steps out of position he
approaches the groomsmen next to him and
reaches into his jacket taking out a
pair of pliers that he hands to the
groomsmen the groomsmen happily takes
the tool and then without any hesitation
shoves the pliers into his mouth and
begins removing his teeth one by one
when he is finished he hands the bloody
teeth to the man along with the pliers
the man then goes to the next groomsmen
who repeats the same process he
continues going down the line until all
of the groomsmen and bridesmaids have
removed their teeth seemingly without
pain or resistance the man then
approaches the bride and groom he hands
each of them half of the pile of teeth
which they gladly accept they then begin
to eat the teeth without delay seemingly
not bothered by the intense damage
they're causing to their own teeth and
Jaws by doing so the man watch watches
as the groom moves the priest who was
officiating the wedding aside as the
entire church looks on in Joy the groom
opens his mouth and the deafening sound
of cicadas are heard this is only the
beginning of what the SCP Foundation has
labeled an
scp-2852 event a terrifying and little
understood phenomenon that is better
known by the nickname of the anomalous
creature responsible for them cousin
Johnny the foundation had been trying to
contain cousin Johnny for decades not
that it ever done them any good Johnny
is a cutter class anomaly that's thus
far proven impossible to contain this is
an entity so dangerous and volatile that
three different mobile task forces are
devoted to detecting and disrupting its
activities MTF Upsilon 36 aka the party
crashers MTF Upsilon 52 AKA cater Duty
and MTF Upsilon 99 AKA The Altar Boys
but so far all the foundation has been
able to really do is Swoop and
afterwards and do their best to pick up
the pieces of people's shattered lives
cousin Johnny has so far been observed
to only operate in the North American
subcontinent and only seems to appear at
Anglican or Catholic baptisms weddings
and funerals however Foundation
operatives charged with keeping a lid on
cousin Johnny Harbor the hidden fear
that he may one day expand his hunting
grounds and wreck Terror worldwide if
Johnny became multinational or
multi-denominational his violence
insanity and pure evil May truly become
impossible to minimize so compatible
communities are constantly monitored for
increased levels of juvenile delinquency
sterility domestic violence and divorce
after all this you're probably wondering
who or what actually is cousin Johnny
and how does he cause so much horrific
tragedy had face value nothing about the
appearance of cousin Johnny would
suggest an anomalous nature or even any
sort of danger he appears to be a
middle-aged white male often with
scruffy hair and a beard on a cellular
level 2 cousin Johnny appears all too
human but when you look at his
physiology it's a whole different story
cousin Johnny has no identifiable organs
whatsoever his body is made out of a
fibrous muscular tissue the only
exceptions are his teeth and hair which
are made out of a kind of chitin a key
component of insect exoskeletons such as
those possessed by cicadas Johnny's eyes
are the first clue that something is off
about him from the distance they appear
perfectly normal but up close they're
glassy and dead this is because his eyes
aren't actually attached to any nerves
inside his head with no nervous system
or vocal cords Johnny's ability to see
move and talk defy any kind of logical
explanation his speech will seem
completely normal to the people under
his spell but to anyone else it comes
out as complete nonsense often described
as word salad if people in attendance
are briefed in advance about this
phenomenon whatever hypnotica bill
ability causes them to hear his sounds
as intelligible words won't work and
they'll be aware of how nonsensical it
all sounds but of course that doesn't
mean they're safe cousin Johnny appears
at family gatherings and religious
rituals and immediately he'll be treated
as though he's always been there you
know your cousin Johnny right you go way
back or at least you're pretty sure you
do nothing will appear unnatural about
his sudden presence in fact if you're
one of the victims of one of his
incidents chances are you'll actually
find yourself taking a shine to cousin
Johnny sure his sense of humor is a
little crude and raunchy but you can't
help but enjoy his company he's a fun
guy to be around and after all he's
family as previously mentioned he'll
only appear at three different kinds of
events baptisms weddings and funerals
and only those that are affiliated with
either the Catholic or Anglican
religions the SCP Foundation has
classified baptisms that cousin Johnny
attends as blue level events weddings
are known as white level events and
funerals are Black Level events with
each one escalating in severity violence
and horror first baptisms the blue level
events in these events cousin Johnny
will appear and begin to act as a third
Godparent despite their traditionally
only being two as the infant is lowered
into the holy water the entirety of
their top layer of skin will come off
like a molting snake despite looking
horrific this apparently causes no harm
to the child the godparents will then
eat this discarded skin as though it's
the most normal thing in the world after
this the family will leave the church
together and cousin Johnny will leave
with them he won't appear at any
subsequent celebrations of the child's
baptism of course this is just the
beginning of the terror following cousin
Johnny's appearance at the baptism the
child's risk of dying in the next six
months skyrockets and if they survive
they're at an increased risk of becoming
unstable and violent later on in life
their parents and godparents will both
become unable to conceive any further
children and are likely to be found dead
from drowning within five years of the
event those who are only tangentially
involved in the baptism ritual have a
massively increased chance of failed
pregnancies or if they do conceive they
may become a danger to their offspring
children who live through blue level
events and survive past adolescents will
experience adverse side effects when
encountering the songs of cicadas well
into adulthood from experiencing
physical sickness to going through
dangerous psychotic episodes weddings or
white level events are more complex and
severe in this case cousin Johnny will
insert himself into the wedding as a
groomsmen and the most horrifying events
will begin to take place after the vows
have been exchanged Johnny will provide
various implements that allow the
Bridesmaids and groomsmen to remove
their teeth which are then given to the
bride and groom to eat which they do
causing severe damage to their own teeth
in the process the groom will then
unvocalize an unknown cicada call at an
incredible volume as loud as 140
decibels in some instances rendering the
bride and everyone else near the altar
completely death at the wedding
reception where everyone is continuing
to behave as if nothing out of the
ordinary is happening cousin Johnny will
ruin things farther by giving the best
man's speech the speech is more of his
typical complete nonsense though if
you're there you'll never realize this
and think that this is the best speech
you've ever heard with some in the
audience laughing hysterically While
others cry uncontrollably once his
speech is done he'll present a gift to
the newly married couple 3.5 kilograms
of human hair in various colors 13
deceased specimens of a certain cicada
known as lynnese cicada and 23 human
teeth in a cardboard box DNA tests on
all the gifts have been inconclusive as
to their origin much like many celebrity
marriages unions that occurred during
white level events Never Last and all
end up divorced within two years often
as a result of domestic violence and any
children born during their brief
marriage will be violent and unstable
but it's not just the wedding party that
gets to experience the fun of a visit
from cousin Johnny all married
individuals who attended the wedding
will find that they are unable to
conceive children despite no biological
indicators of infertility any children
present at the white level event will
show no interest in Romance throughout
their life and often die tragically
before reaching the age of 18. finally
and most horrifying of all are funerals
or black level events while blue and
white level events can potentially be
disrupted before they are completed
lessening or preventing the horrific
results there is as yet no way to stop
or prevent a black level event at any
stage any attempts to prevent cousin
Johnny from entering the church or
Funeral Home will lead him to Simply
manifesting inside once in the room
where the funeral is taking place cousin
Johnny will first take up the role of
eulogizer and begin speaking his
standard nonsense to the attendance the
person who was emotionally closest to
The Departed will then open the casket
if this was not already an open casket
funeral and will then produce a large
knife it's unknown where the knives come
from as they're not present before the
event and they disappear after the
funeral attendees will then use the
knife on their wrists and sometimes
throats draining their blood into the
coffin many lose more than enough blood
to result in death but none ever die
from this nor do they seem to feel any
pain from their wounds as the attendees
take turns bleeding into the coffin
cousin Johnny continues his eulogy which
eventually evolves into a cicada song
the kind song by lynnae's cicada males
the attendants sing the same song back
to him in a kind of call and response
cousin Johnny will then approach the
coffin and vomit in a mixture of blood
wood pulp and dead cicadas the funeral
will then proceed as normal and the
blood vomit and cicada-filled casket is
then taken to the cemetery and Buried
Black Level events will usually end with
the body being interred in the ground
but if there's a wake after the funeral
the horrors of the Black Level event
will continue at the Wake cousin Johnny
will climb on top of a table lie down
and encourage the other attendants to
devour him which they do all the while
he continues to talk his nonsense until
there is nothing left much like blue and
white level events being in attendance
leads to horrific After Effects all
participants who experience this event
will separate from their family through
either suicide moving or divorce every
individual present at the event will
also find that they are no longer able
to produce Offspring and couples
presence may also fall victim to
incidencies of domestic violence often
involving cannibalism that usually leave
one or both participants dead while 6
out of 10 children involved will attempt
to murder one or both of their parents
before they turn 18. these black level
events are so horrible for all involved
that any members of the specialized
cousin Johnny mobile task forces that
happen to witness such an event are
treated with class A amnestics before
they are transferred to another task
force or retire to ensure that they
don't have to live with the memories of
what they saw prior to that they are
closely monitored for any strange or
anti-social Behavior to make sure they
weren't affected by the event and they
aren't the only SCP Foundation staff at
risk of having been impacted by cousin
Johnny it is theorized that as many as a
third of Catholic and Anglican d-class
Personnel were involved in the Black
Level event at some point and were
driven to Madness and violence by their
fateful brushes with the strange
relative that no one knows so next time
you're out of baptism or a wedding or a
funeral stay vigilant keep an eye on the
other guests and always ask yourself do
you really have a cousin Johnny you hear
their footsteps coming down the halls or
are those your own can you even tell the
difference you can tell they're getting
closer and you can feel the hate the
rage you turn shaking and finally see
them standing right in front of you but
in that moment you might as well be
looking into a mirror and who knows
perhaps you are you just don't seem to
remember having so many Reflections have
you ever heard the saying you are Your
Own Worst Enemy of course it isn't
usually meant literally but what if it
was what if you had to fight a monster
that was you all of your flaws are
reflected back at you your strengths
your weaknesses your deepest fears with
no way to escape except a battle to the
death either way you're not making it
out alive it's just a matter of which
version of you survives but this isn't a
thought experiment no according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation it's very
much a reality there is a place where
this nightmare comes to life and it's
known as
scp-1919
scp-1919 is a hotel and converted
Mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built and
it almost looks like a comfortable place
to stay if you ignore the Eastern side
of the building that is sunk partially
into the ground the inside however is a
different story where it's clear the
ravages of time have taken their toll
the floorboards and ceilings are rotting
collapsing in on themselves and the
rooms are filled with debris it's deadly
enough to explore the hotel for these
reasons alone but this is only the
beginning of the danger for a person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person or
group to enter the structure the SCP
Foundation planned a series of research
Expeditions into the abandoned building
led by Foundation scientist Dr lemkowitz
the first expedition seemed relatively
normal at least it did at the start a 39
year old Caucasian d-class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a
camera and a communication system guided
remotely by Dr limkowitz or Dr Al and
another operative a former head of the
MTF tau-11 youth hostiles who is
referred to in this file only as t11
when he arrived at the building D7 was
unable to get inside through the front
door or Windows after several minutes of
trial and error he was finally able to
get in through the Western entrance Dr L
picked up a strange high-pitched
Whistling noise upon d7's entrance into
the building but it quickly faded away
and was disregarded by t11 D7 discovered
a torn painting a portrait of a young
woman with red hair next to the portrait
shallow scratches could be seen in the
wall the floor and parts of the ceiling
suddenly D7 ducked into a hiding place
alarm he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing and it didn't belong to
D7 Dr L recommended that D7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity
inside but t11 overruled ordering him to
disregard that instruction and continue
his investigation D7 was told to stay at
a safe distance from whatever was inside
with him an attempt to capture it on
video D7 turned off his flashlight in
order to better hide but t11 commanded
that he turn it back on whatever was
caught in the beam of light was
difficult for the camera to see but it
threw D7 into a panic and he began to
run in the opposite direction when
prompted to explain what he saw D7
simply said it was me D7 ran through the
dark panting with fear and exertion
unable to see where his feet were
Landing he tripped over something and
came crashing onto the ground dropping
the video camera this allowed the
observing officers to finally see what
D7 was so frightened by and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified a man
identical looking to D7 approached from
the end of the hallway making its way
towards the real D7 it was followed by
another man who also resembled D7 and
another all running toward the original
they all looked exactly like him with a
few notable differences they were
dressed in the same uniform with the
same build and the same features but
each had something slightly off about
him one was missing eyelids another had
malformed hands and the third had its
lips fused together into a fleshy Mass
beneath its nose Dr L moved to cut the
camera feed but t11 demanded that it be
kept running D7 couldn't be seen by the
camera but the microphone picked up the
sounds of Flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained Panic screams as the
duplicates set upon him after a moment
the screaming stopped two hours later
the camera was broken and the Expedition
brought to a troubling end this was the
foundation's first Glimpse at the
creatures inside of us
scp-1919 and it was not pretty it did
however allow them to begin
understanding the nature of the building
and what happens when a person goes
inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel several humanoid
creatures manifest throughout the
building these creatures look like this
subject and are equipped with the same
clothing or items that the subject
brought inside with them though they are
nearly mirror images of the subject they
are always slightly warped in a variety
of ways these have included changes to
Limb and digit length joint Mobility
sealed nostrils lengthen Jaws hanging
loose and Limp missing eyelids and lips
that are fused together these creatures
are highly aggressive towards the
structure of the building itself as well
as to the subject that they resemble
they do not however attack each other
they appear to operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant Colonnade once they have been
spawned by the entrance of a new person
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed
after the unfortunate end to the
Expedition the foundation prepped for a
second trip inside this time three men
were sent in with Dr L's guidance known
as D3 D4 and D9 video cameras were sewn
into their clothes to leave their hands
free and help avoid some of the issues
that came up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of D7 and further examine the hotel's
interior upon opening the door to the
building they were immediately attacked
by one of d-7's copies which D9 was able
to quickly dispatch by firing his weapon
at its head next after a great deal of
reluctance the three men entered the
building where they spotted something
unusual inside Dr Al was horrified when
the camera feed revealed 17 discarded
video cameras spread across the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however because two
doubles one mirroring D7 and another
mirroring Dean 9 emerge from the wall
and began to attack Dr Al ordered the
team to take shelter then called the
team of guards outside of the hotel's
perimeter they were ordered to begin an
immediate full perimeter lockdown
preventing the doubles from leaving the
hotel D3 D4 and D9 attempted to make
their way to a safe corner of the
building but found themselves met with a
murderous double at every turn at this
point Dr Al began to hear an unusual
sound over the microphone feed a
high-pitched wine like that of a dentist
drill the operatives on the ground
couldn't hear a thing but on Dr L's end
it was deafening as the team proceeded
deeper into the hotel they became
overcome with a strange feeling of
foreboding Dr Al ordered them to turn on
their flashlights but they refused and
begged Dr L to keep quiet when prompted
to explain d-9 said she can hear you the
operatives stop responding but their
camera feeds caught a faint glowing
white light coming from beneath the door
the door opened and the light flooded
the camera making the images it captured
hard to decipher just a few frames of a
quick moving female silhouette were
captured before the cameras cut to
static the bodies of D3 D4 and D9 were
never recovered nor were their cameras a
third expedition was also sent into
scp-1919 but very little is known about
what occurred during it the video
transcript is highly classified and only
those present for its events or proved
to research
scp-1919 have access to it an update to
the scp-1919 file following Expedition 3
though indicates that new information
was revealed about the hotel during the
Excursion according to the file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing
all of the other creatures the doubles
to appear the only information available
about this being is the use of the word
her in the official Foundation log about
scp-1919 this seems to match up with the
last moments of the operatives in
Expedition 2 when they told Dr L that
she can hear you and the few frames of a
female figure that were captured by
their cameras nothing else is known that
has been made available to anyone
outside of very select few only the
original report exists and all other
copies of it have been destroyed the
foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel Escape whether they are the evil
twins spawned by humans entering the
building or the mysterious female being
at the center of the entire disturbing
phenomenon the foundation has classified
scp-1919 as Euclid and a two kilometer
radius must be maintained around
scp-1919 with all roads leading to the
building are blocked or diverted so that
no vehicles are able to reach it this
perimeter is guarded by a set of at
least 40 armed and armored guards at any
given time as it has been determined
that the doubles spawn by 1919 are
equipped with whatever the human they
are copying has no one is allowed to
enter the hotel with body armor or
weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official Expedition team will
be immediately terminated no new
Expedition teams are allowed to enter
the building unless all doubles from the
previous Expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated enough time must
elapse between Expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the doubles do need to eat to survive
and will die when left alone for long
enough
scp-1919 has been sealed off from the
rest of the world so that no hapless
civilians can wander inside and find
themselves Torn to Pieces by warped
images of themselves but that Comfort
turns cold when you realize that the SCP
Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn is it
scientific Supernatural or something
else no one can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of all of this an unknown female
presence capable of wrecking frightening
amounts of Violence by turning victims
own images against them what is the
purpose of these fun house mirror
nightmares who is she what is she and
what does she want currently the doubles
have shown no interest in leaving the
hotel except to attack Intruders and
thanks to that fact as well as the
reinforced perimeter outside these
copycats have not appeared outside of
the building itself but what happens if
they do Escape or if the entity that
controls them decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move Beyond its current containment are
you prepared to fight a vision of
yourself Twisted almost Beyond ignition
lunging after you with wide bulbous eyes
unnaturally long arms and a distended
jaw hanging down below its neck better
hope you never have to find out in high
school the days tend to blend together
after a while math test unrequited love
Annoying group project stress rinse
repeat sometimes a big football game or
a school dance or maybe a fight in the
hallway breaks up the monotony a bit but
it's normally pretty uneventful it's
always fine by me I've never tried to be
a popular kid or the center of attention
I prefer to keep my head down work stage
crew for the school plays and just hang
out with the same small group of friends
I've known since we were little kids it
was on one of those ordinary days in a
long line of similarly ordinary days
that something came to destroy the
peaceful High School existence I'd
gotten used to as I sat in History Class
passing notes with my best friend Zach
and ignoring a video about the Civil War
I had no idea that I was about to live
through the worst day of my life and I
would be one of the lucky ones I'd
survive the others let's just say they
wouldn't be so lucky I was just
scribbling a response to Zach something
about hanging out and playing Xbox after
school when the PA system crackled to
life our principal's voice cut through
the droning narration about the Battle
of Antietam as he spoke staff F this is
a lockdown initiate your lockdown
procedures immediately if you're a
visitor outside the building please
leave the property immediately and call
9-1-1 I assumed it was just another
lockdown drill until I saw my teacher's
face she looked pale her expression
tight like she was trying to hold it
together for our benefit I could see her
hand shaking as she reached to turn off
the video when I heard the Tremor in her
voice I knew for sure she was terrified
this was not a drill as our teacher
locked the door and we all climbed under
our desk to crouch in the dark and wait
out the lockdown I could hear my
classmates Whispering furvishly everyone
was trying to figure out what was going
on someone suggested a kid had brought a
knife to school someone wondered aloud
if a threat had been called into the
principal's office Zach cracked a dumb
joke about a mutated frog escaping from
the biology lab when suddenly a scream
rang out echoing down the hall have you
ever felt an entire room of people
holding their breath at once if we
listened for the sound of fighting for
gunshots anything nothing and then
another scream louder closer and longer
than the last it was the scream of pure
unadulterated fear and pain that
dissolved into a wet gurgle that made my
stomach turn Zach and I shared a look
when that said whatever's going on it's
like nothing we've ever seen before I
could feel my chest tightening and it
was getting harder to breathe I tucked
my head between my knees holding on to
the back of my head and trying to take
in deep gulps of air the room felt as if
it tilted on its side and I thought I
might pass out another sound brought me
back to Earth it was coming from the
back wall of the classroom by the
chalkboard the sound of liquid sloshing
onto the floor mixed with plaster
splintering apart and pieces clattering
all over I try to get a better look but
the room was dark and I didn't want to
leave the relative safety of my desk if
there was someone or something coming
into the room I didn't want it to see me
Zach had a better angle than me I could
see him craning his neck to get a better
look when he clasped a hand over his
mouth in shock I heard him scream
muffled against his hand what had he
seen what was it if before I could even
ask my teachers cry rippled through the
darkness and the silence get out get out
she repeated over and over again and I
could hear the raw desperation in her
voice it was like someone ushering
passengers off of the sinking Titanic
someone who knows there is no hope for
them but hopes they can at least save
the children before it all goes down Run
for the love of God just run her voice
broke from fear from pain or both and
the sound was enough to get my legs
working again my classmates had the same
response and we blindly rushed for the
door flipping over desks and knocking
chairs to the side as we scrambled for
an exit Zach grabbed my arm and I held
on tight afraid I would lose him in the
chaos someone unlocked the door and we
poured into the Hall just as I made it
out of the door I couldn't help but turn
back and look call it morbid curiosity
call it Instinct called stupidity but I
had to see what happened I turned just
in time to see a nightmare brought to
life the wall was melting covered in
something thick black and putrid the
smell invaded my nostrils and I gagged
on it her wretched gray arm had its
fingers wrapped around the teacher's
wrist skin peeling off to reveal muscle
and bone it looked like it belonged to a
corpse but it gripped her within human
strength she was pulling with all her
might but I watched helplessly as the
arm pulled her into the melted wall like
she weighed nothing swallowing her body
and her screams with it and then she was
gone Zach tugged on my arm hard yanking
me into the Hall come on man run he
hadn't seen what I'd seen or he would
have realized that running might not be
enough whatever this thing was it didn't
play by any rules I knew running was all
we had right now though so we ran I
looked around for a weapon something
anything I could use to defend myself
but I couldn't see anything that would
help instead all I saw was the
destruction the Intruder had left in its
wake all around me a hall as I walked
through every day were falling to pieces
they weren't just damaged they were
coming apart at the seams lockers were
warped beyond recognition walls
completely dissolved sections of the
floor reduced to sizzling puddles of goo
and everywhere everything was covered in
that same black slime it smelled worse
than you could ever imagine it smelled
like the complete loss of Hope at the
point of no return it smelled like death
we reached the end of the hall when I
heard something shifting behind us I
suddenly became aware that we were alone
the sound of frantic footsteps hushed
Whispers door slamming out in locking
had all quieted where was everyone I
glanced over my shoulder and saw one
lone figure shambling down the hall
towards us it was far away and I could
scarcely make it out in the darkness but
I could hear tripping sizzling and the
smell of Decay growing stronger that was
not a classmate or a teacher whatever it
was it was taking people away or killing
them I didn't know exactly what but
whatever it was doing to everyone Zach
and I were next on its list the scariest
part was how slowly it moved maybe its
legs were too rotten to move any faster
joints disintegrating into useless mush
but it seemed more deliberate than that
to me in my Panic clouded mine had seen
that it was just taking its time it
didn't need to rush he knew that when it
wanted to catch its prey it would I
couldn't suppress this sick feeling in
my stomach this time I killed over and
vomited onto the floor when I looked up
Zach was beckoning me from just inside
the doors to the auditorium come on in
here he could have left me behind for
the Intruder to take and try to save
himself and sacrifice slow friend Frozen
in place with Terror but here he was
looking out for me again even in this
horrible situation I felt a surge of
gratitude I booked it across the floor
forgetting for a moment about the
shuffling corpse making its way towards
us and joined my best friend in the
auditorium it was Eerie in the dark the
curtains soaking up and dampening sounds
barely any light Illuminating the
normally cheerful props and backdrops
left from a recent production of Alice
in Wonderland a once friendly Place felt
twisted like a mockery of Wonderland
with a monster stalking outside and
waiting to pounce we sat on the stage
listening to the sound of our labored
breathing the air felt heavy but I
welcome the smell of paint and dust over
the nauseating stench that permeated the
rest of the school
are we the only ones left Zack whispered
breaking the silence he was the first
one to say what we were both thinking
what we both feared no I said with false
confidence I think some of them got out
before I couldn't finish the sentence
somebody had to get out it can't just be
us I lean my head against a giant paper
mache Toadstool thought it was too dark
for Zach to see the tears filling my
eyes what was that thing he asked did
you see it I sat up straighter I thought
I was the only one who got a look at the
thing however fleeting no but I I heard
it and smelled it he coughed it took me
a while to answer his question
eventually I found the word it's evil we
sat in silence for a long while after
that I don't know exactly how long
moments like that were at any second you
could be lost forever time stretches out
into something unrecognizable I was
starting to think foolishly that we
might be in the clear when I heard a
strange sound it was a creaking like
footsteps on the an old wooden floor I
looked around for the source of the
noise but I couldn't see anything it
sounded close impossibly close Creek
One Step than the mother where was that
coming from there's no wood floor in the
hall nothing above us by the time I
understood it was too late the top of a
head slimy clammy and gray with Tufts of
Limp white hair clinging to the soft
flesh began to emerge from the stage
where we sat eyes Hollow and dead but
somehow alert and searching for us came
next followed by a gaping wound where a
nose should be and a wide toothless grin
it looked almost like a person but it
was wrong just wrong every cell in my
body rejected it screaming at me with
thousands of years of animal Instinct
that I had to run I grab Zack's arm and
yanked but he didn't come with me I
turned a look and my heart jumped into
my throat it had him its bony fingers I
had a hold on his legs and he was
already halfway gone pulled into the
Slick Black puddle in the stage his face
was damped with tears as the reality of
his fate set in he grabbed my hand in
his and squeezed Ron was all he could
get out before the old man pulled him
out of sight so I obeyed my best
friend's wish I ran and I hid in the
prop closet hand over my mouth to stifle
my breathing suddenly there was a loud
bang and I heard voices yelling
something that sounded like a gunshot a
blast of bright light and a voicemail
and official sounding called out is
anyone in here you can come out or with
the police I opened the closet door and
peered out to see hazmat suits wielding
bizarre weapons and carrying devices I'd
never seen before the man who had spoken
approached me took my hand and asked me
if I'd seen anything I got the strong
sense that I should definitely not tell
him what I'd seen uh no sir I said he
nodded whether you believe me or not he
knew I wouldn't say anything more gas
leak he said destroyed large parts of
the building highly dangerous we need to
get you out of here they took me home
and I hugged my parents tighter than I
ever had before that night the news
covered the tragedy at my school the gas
leak had taken dozens of lives before
the authorities had gotten there
everyone else can accept the story all
they want I know the truth I see it when
I close my eyes imagine it standing over
me when I wake up in the dead of night
those Hollow eyes that horrible smile
the stench of death and rot it looked
right at me it saw me it wanted I can't
let myself think about what it wanted I
don't know exactly what I saw but I know
a few things for certain there was no
gas leak Zach and the rest of the people
it took are gone and if that monster
ever escapes it's coming after me next
throwing indestructible lizards into
Vats of acid hunting strange chicken men
through forests in Ireland arguing in
Latin with a man wearing a haunted Roman
centurion's helmet when you join the SCP
Foundation you might be expecting high
octane drama of the time especially with
the name street sweepers you'd expect
this mobile task force to be neck deep
in some real action-packed street racing
maybe you wouldn't think that they'd be
tasked with driving all day every day in
four hour shifts tailing A semi-truck
all over Birmingham Alabama but as agent
Moore and his colleague pulled into the
lay-by behind the truck neither of them
were ready for what they were about to
witness
scp-2590 was first discovered by the
foundation at a routine traffic stop
investigating a totally different
anomaly in the Birmingham area agents
Peters and Smith had been posing as
local police officers the foundation had
been trying to track down an artifact
that was supposedly being smuggled
across the U.S in the back of a
nondescript station wagon Peterson Smith
had been allocated a pair of beat-up old
police cruisers which they'd parked
across the dirt road fully blocking any
traffic from coming through it was
several hours into their shift when the
incident occurred just at the point they
were starting to lose focus taking a
look through the suitcases in
memorabilia from a family's trip to
Disney World Peters had taken way too
long to hear the noise of the engine
swelling behind him he spun around to
see the hulking shape of the semi-truck
barreling straight towards him agent
Smith and a family of five with only two
seconds to react he yelled out at the
top of his lungs and dived out of the
way leaving the trunk of the car wide
open with five screams emerging from
inside Smith who had been sitting in one
of the Cruisers only just managed to get
out before the semi made contact eyes
closed agent Peters waited for the
inevitable sound of screaming rubber the
bang of metal on metal and the shower of
Glass on asphalt but it never came when
he opened his eyes the station wagon was
still parked up in front of them the two
police crews are still blocking the road
and off the Disney merch still piled
high in the trunk the semi was driving
off along the road on the other side of
their blockade with not a scratch on it
without a moment's hesitation agent
Smith who had kept his eyes open and
witnessed the whole thing leapt into
action he ordered his partner still
lying confused in the dirt to administer
Class A and nestics to the family and
call in for backup agent Smith himself
jammed his keys into the ignition
twisting them so hard he almost bent the
metal and took off after the vehicle
what agent Smith and Peters had just
witnessed was the very first Foundation
Asian exposure to
scp-2590 fondly nicknamed trailer trash
as Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle
and studied it for the first time he
made a note of its initial appearance
over the radio an appearance which
remains unchanged years later the badges
on the vehicle claim that it is an
International ProStar day cab
semi-trailer truck complete with an
unmarked trailer as the agent flicked on
his lights and indicated that the
vehicle should pull over he noted that
it didn't have any license plates on it
either front or rear he leaned forward
in his seat trying to peer into the cab
to make out the driver but in the
Alabama Sun the man just looked like a
shadowy figure they drove side by side
along the road for almost a mile the
truck made no signs of pulling over
despite agent Smith's continued
insistence and repeated flashes of the
cop lights but it also didn't attempt to
pull away either it just continued to
drive a few miles per hour below the
speed limit the driver didn't seem to
look across at him once having discussed
it with Foundation staff they decided it
was best not to draw attention to the
situation they had no idea whether this
SCP was hostile or posed any threat to
civilian life but having blue and red
lights flashing at it appeared to be
doing little to change the situation
instead he switched off the sirens and
pulled in behind the truck tailing it
around Birmingham as the foundation
readied for their agents to respond to
the situation for almost an hour nothing
of note happened agent Smith drove
behind the trailer watching it like a
hawk he observed that it obeyed every
traffic law to a t it never broke the
speed limit never cut anyone off and
left room for other vehicles to merge if
it hadn't seen it drive straight through
a roadblock as if it wasn't there he
would have never suspected a thing but
then the truck turned its turn signal on
they had just come off the highway and
merged onto a quiet side street just as
the sun was starting to hang low in the
sky
the truck crept across the side of the
road squeezing its brakes gently and
stopped agent Smith matched the action
the whole way pulling up about 20 feet
behind the trailer in constant radio
communication he kicked open his door
and stepped out into the evening air
Foundation Personnel advised that he
keep his hand on his gun at all times
and approach with caution he didn't
really need them to tell him that Smith
called for the driver to step out of the
cab no response the truck just sat there
with its hazards on engine off after a
moment there was a clunk and the trailer
door started to slowly open all by
itself agent Smith called in backup but
there were still several minutes out
instead he ran back to the car gun
raised and waited to see what was inside
as the doors slowly opened to reveal
nothing no not quite nothing there was
something small on the floor of the
trailer right in the center as if it
hadn't been moved around at all by the
vehicle's motion it was red a kind of
elongated Cube
he reported it all to the foundation
over his radio then paused when he
recognized what it was a KitKat candy
bar or to be more specific a Kit Kat
chunky what happened after this point
was hazy agent Smith was found on the
roadside just 20 minutes later confused
about what had happened the truck was
nowhere in sight however a security
camera from a convenience store just up
the street happened to capture the
interaction in the footage you see agent
Smith approaching the trailer with his
gun raised looking at the KitKat he
tries to enter the trailer but is unable
to so he approaches the driver's side
door while talking to the shadowy figure
in the cab he drops his gun and stands
motionless a confused and sleepy
expression on his face until the trailer
door closes and the SCP drives away
contact was re-established with scp-2590
soon after and has been maintained
almost uninterrupted ever since the
findings made on that initial encounter
seem to hold true across further
examination Personnel have reached out
to Navistar International the company
that supposedly manufactures this model
of semi-truck but there appears to be no
records of its creation or shipment to
the U.S in fact no documentation at all
can be attributed to the truck or any
components on it the driver in the front
cab is a humanoid figure who is
perpetually shrouded in Shadow
designated
scp-2590-1 attempts to reveal the
driver's figures have proved ineffective
as even powerful spotlights do not shed
enough light into the cab to render the
driver visible quite what this driver's
role is in the operation of scp-2590 is
unknown
scp-2590-1 appears to have some
proximity-based amnestic qualities as
anyone approaching it on foot has
reported memory loss and confusion soon
after just like agent Smith as also
discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock containment of this SCP is
simply not possible while the majority
of the time the SCP is corporeal it
possesses the ability to pass through
solid objects at will all attempted
roadblocks have resulted in the same
thing happening the SCP will just phase
right through on them as if nothing was
there since it cannot be contained in
the usual way a different operation has
been set up to monitor the truck's
activities which so far have proven to
be apparently harmless to the civilian
population mobile task force gamma 133
also known as the street sweepers has
been established to follow this SCP
around Birmingham at all times they
operate in four-hour shifts with two
agents in unmarked Vehicles sticking
close behind the trailer at all times
the foundation was able to fit a
tracking device onto it as well
providing researchers with continuous
location data for where they can find
the vehicle at seemingly random times
supposedly determined by the SCP itself
it pulls over somewhere quiet and opens
the door to its trailer the door will
remain open for 60 seconds and then
close again any attempts to enter the
trailer have been blocked by some kind
of invisible barrier seemingly
impenetrable to most approaches more
violent and destructive methods of Entry
cannot be authorized for testing due to
the heavy civilian population in the
surrounding area every time the doors
open there is something different in the
trailer researchers are trying to
ascertain some kind of pattern or
messaging behind most of the objects but
many seem to be random the current list
of things that have appeared in the back
of scp-2590 include an iPhone 3G a red
apple and a lit light bulb without any
visible form of power supply most
notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human
beings as happened on the night that
agent Moore was on duty in the street
sweepers the agents pulled in behind the
truck as per usual when it slowed to a
stop beside the highway agent Moore got
out of the vehicle second unenthused
about the monotony of the task he had
been assigned expecting to see a
cardboard box or a ChapStick when the
trailer door opened he was left shocked
when he came face to face with himself
few people can say they have seen
themselves in real life most of them
have been administered with various
amnestics to make them forget but agent
Moore went on to report how bizarre of
an experience it was he claimed that it
was utterly unlike looking in a mirror
where your reflection is flipped and
follows your every move seeing yourself
standing in three dimensions moving
independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress is an experience that
few would envy anytime a human being
materializes in the trailer they appear
to be in a great deal of distress as
they attempt to escape through the
invisible barrier agent Moore and his
partner agent Hall could do nothing but
stand and watch in confusion as the copy
of him attempted to free himself before
after the usual 60 seconds the trailer
door closed
the vehicle pulled away again several
instances have occurred of duplicate
humans appearing in the trailer but each
time the original person seems to have
had no knowledge of this taking place
and nothing out of the ordinary happens
to them however there appears to be some
small pattern demonstrating the SCP as
an awareness of the foundation as it has
also duplicated agent inglis's sister
who has no connection to this SCP at all
incident 16 was the most distressing of
all as a large slab of metal appeared in
the back of the trailer with the SCP
Foundation logo painted across it agent
Inglis and Schultz were on duty at this
time and observed copious amounts of
blood flowing out of the metal slab
before long the blood filled the back of
the trailer pushing up against the
invisible barrier all of a sudden 52
seconds into the encounter the barrier
vanished and a Cascade of blood with the
slab inside were launched out of the two
agents at a speed of over 190 kilometers
an hour killing them both instantly
since this incident
scp-2590 has been treated with greater
caution the most mysterious thing to
have come from researching this truck
came on December 4th 2011 when for the
first time the truck's tracking Beacon
stopped working it had been seen pulling
into an abandoned warehouse and so a
team of street sweepers was immediately
dispatched to investigate when they
arrived they found the vehicle moving
through the warehouse at a slow crawl
choosing to pursue on foot and leave a
pair of agents at the entrance they
followed the SCP through the facility
until it came to what agents described
as a service tunnel or sewer of some
sort putting headlamps on they followed
the truck down into the tunnel
maintaining radio contact throughout as
they reported the direction they were
traveling and the distance it quickly
became apparent to Foundation Personnel
that this was no ordinary tunnel the
warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff and so the geography was not
physically possible as the street
sweepers descended it further into the
tunnel they noted there was increased
levels of carbon monoxide radio contacts
started to dip in and out losing signal
as they went further downhill just at
the edge of their signal with the
foundation the truck stopped and opened
its trailer door inside was just a
single piece of parchment with the words
I'm just delivering a message written on
it after the usual 60 seconds the
trailer door closed and the truck
continued after they had passed the
kilometer Mark the radio signal worsened
quickly and after a couple of scrambled
messages the team down there were not
heard from again the channel stayed open
for another six hours before the
foundation made the decision to announce
the agents missing in action in March
2015 over three years later a radio
signal came into contact with the
foundation again from Birmingham Alabama
it was from the headset of the squad
leader who had gone into the tunnel
initially confused as to who had gained
access to the comms channel the
foundation demanded that the agent state
has full name and rank the agent himself
confused obliged questioning why they
were so suspicious he and his team
claimed to have only lost contact for
about 15 minutes they had followed the
FCP a little further until carbon
monoxide levels had risen too high to
continue at which point they had watched
the truck disappearing into the distance
as they walked back to the surface all
agents have undergone extensive
psychological Rehabilitation to settle
them back into society as well as
classes to fill them in on things like
the London Olympics the Ice Bucket
Challenge and Gangnam Style as for
scp-2590 it is back out on the roads
roaming around Birmingham Alabama
continuously never stopping for fuel
always obeying the rules of the road
occasionally opening its trailer doors
to reveal new and bizarre findings a
d-class drag races through the testing
Zone screaming at the top of his lungs
and doing donuts a mime who is also in
the testing chamber stares with
disapproval tapping his foot impatiently
did we mention that the car is made of
spiders yeah this one is going to be a
weird one folks stay tuned for one of
the craziest SCP stories you've ever
heard Emily had always dreamed of taking
a trip to Paris but the opportunity
actually came to visit the city she was
overjoyed she spent her time exploring
art museums tasting the bread and cheese
and walking through the city streets
taking in the sights one of her favorite
things about Paris was all the street
performers as she walked nibbling on a
panel chocolate she delighted in the
antics of jugglers tossing colorful
balls into the air she gasped at the
feet of athleticism and Grace
demonstrated by acrobats and
contortionists she giggled that the
Absurd shows put on by puppeteers and
dabbed tears from her eyes at the sound
of beautiful songs played and sung by
musicians it became part of her daily
routine one night as Emily was walking
back to her hostel after a long language
dinner she found herself walking down
the street she had not encountered
before there was no one around except
for her it was a lovely moment of Peace
but it also struck her as a little bit
eerie and she wished for The Familiar
throngs of people up ahead she spotted
the silhouette of another person and let
out a sigh of relief as she got closer
she could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret the white face makeup rouged
cheeks and red lips a mime a real
classic French mime she couldn't believe
her luck when he spotted Emily
approaching the Mind began to start a
performance he began with a classic the
invisible box he felt around the walls
of the invisible box looking out with
exaggerated wide eyes and an open mouth
Emily clapped and reached into her bag
for a little bit of money she could use
to tip him after all he was putting on a
performance just for her he deserved it
she walked closer to the mime looking
for a place to put her tip she didn't
see one so she held up her hand offering
the money directly to the mime as he
took notice of how close she was getting
the mime began shaking his head
vigorously eyes wide and insistent she
didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her until it was too late dozens
and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mime's face out from inside of
his clothes from his shoes pouring out
over the street and crawling up onto
Emily she tried to brush them off she
tried to run away but no matter how hard
she tried the spiders just kept coming
all she could do was scream in an
attempt to experience a little bit of
live performance Emily unwittingly came
across
scp-3247
scp-3247 is a humanoid entity standing
at approximately 1.7 meters in height it
wears a striped shirt and suspenders
similar to the Garb of a stereotypical
French mime as was what appears to be
white makeup on its face and all other
Exposed Skin though these aspects of its
appearance seem as if they should be
removable the clothing and makeup are in
fact parts of the entity's physiology
and cannot be removed from its body this
is not the only unusual aspect of the
entity's physical form though it looks
corporeal and solid The Entity cannot
touch or directly interact with any
solid matter with one particular
exception there is a colony of spiders
living on and inside of
scp-3247 these spiders have officially
been designated as
cp-3247-a and are highly protective of
scp-3247 if anyone or anything attempts
to approach
scp-3247 in a threatening manner the
spiders will swarm the Potential Threat
as any Savvy anomalous activity
enthusiasts might have already gathered
these are of course no order ordinary
spiders not only do they dwell on and in
an intangible mime but they have a
peculiar response to witnessing a human
being making specific gestures or
pantomiming activities when this occurs
the colony of spiders will form the
shape of an object related to the
gestures which they will then hold for
up to three hours or until given
additional stimuli that prompt a change
in shape while the spider colony is
assembled into shape they will be able
to share some of the given objects
functions in spite of being technically
nothing more than a massive
well-coordinated arachnids as for
scp-3247 it is either incapable of
speech or unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent liming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively living props
scp-3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propless r art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother
scp-3247 in order to better understand
the nature of
scp-3247-a foundation staff conducted a
series of tests in each test a d-class
was given a gesture to perform in the
presence of
scp-3247 then the research staff would
record the spider colony's response
during the first test the research staff
ordered d-11424 to attempt to get as
close to
scp-3247 as possible they did not of
course warn him about the spiders he
entered the testing chamber and
approached the mime who was pantomiming
the act of climbing stairs as the mime
pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase and d11424 grew closer
instances of
scp-3247-a emerged to take the shape of
a staircase much to the mime's
frustration
scp-3240 7 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to d11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with
scp-3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him
d-11424 began to wave frantically at the
mime the mime simply Shrugged giving him
a look that said well what do you want
me to do about it at this point control
intervened instructing d11424 to
pantomime some kind of activity
fortunately before turning to a life of
crime
d11424 had spent several years in a
professional improv troupe and was well
acquainted with pantomime his performing
instincts kicked in and he leapt into
action he put a hand to his ear as if
listening to the ringing of a telephone
the spiders stopped their attack
responding immediately to his Q they
formed into the shape of a small table
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on
top the mime rolled its eyes in disdain
at the side of this prop based
performance but d11424 was on a roll he
crossed to the phone picked up the
receiver and held it to his ear hello he
asked out of habit he wasn't expecting
to hear a voice on the other line but
then he did or rather he heard the
approximation of a human voice created
by a swarm of anomalous spiders it
sounded a bit like a human voice sped up
high-pitched and squeaky speaking some
sort of gibberish realizing that this
was his moment to escape
d-11424 placed the phone back in place
and promptly left the testing chamber
the spiders remained in the shape of the
rotary phone and the table for the next
two hours at which point they
disassembled and returned to their home
on
scp-3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11424 would be the designated test
subject for all future testing with
scp-3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders
d11424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to scp-682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test d11424
knew what to expect from
scp-3247 for this test he was told to
pantomime playing tug of war with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves into the shapes of
a long rope one side of which was in
d-11424's hands as well as a large
humanoid vaguely muscular in shape that
was holding the other side of the Rope
the spiders gave the the Rope a sharp
tug causing d11424 to lose his balance
and fall over the Rope slipping out of
his grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three
d-11424 was instructed to enter the
testing chamber and close his fist while
extending the thumb and index finger in
a gesture colloquially known as finger
guns sure enough as soon as he assumed
this position the spiders assembled into
the shape of a handgun d-11424 was then
instructed to pick up the spider gun and
squeeze the place where the trigger
would be if it was a real gun and not
you know spiders a loud cracking sound
was heard when the d-class squeezed as a
spider shot out of the barrel of the gun
at high speed before smacking into the
nearby wall leaving a small hole in the
surface
d-11424 fired several more times each
Shot firing an individual spider at a
pace that attending researchers
described as faster than a speeding
bullet after firing six rounds of spider
at the wall
d11424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76
d11424 was ordered to hold his hands
together and wiggle four fingers on each
hand effectively pantomiming a spider
the research team was curious to see
what the spiders would do when presented
with a shape that matched their usual
unassembled form
scp-3247 who generally did not react
much to the experiments on its spiders
began shaking its head in mild
disappointment as approximately
640 spiders emerge from its body
dividing themselves into groups of eight
each group of eight spiders then joined
to form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point d11424 followed
his heart jumping onto the mega spider's
back and riding it like a bull at the
rodeo as the spider bucked and ran back
and forth across the room according to
official transcripts d-11424 yelled ye
ha throughout this part of the test
until the head researcher ordered him to
climb down from the spider and exit the
room he was reprimanded for his behavior
and warned that if he acted without
approval again he would be taken off the
project and reassigned to a much less
enjoyable position as one of the
designated eyes on SCP-173
d-11424 immediately agreed to comply
with future instructions during test
number 133
d-11424 was sent into the testing
chamber and told to Shadowbox he danced
back and forth across the cell doing his
best Sylvester Stallone impression and
throwing punches in the general
direction of the spiders in response
approximately 3 000 spiders poured out
of
scp-3247 assembling into the shadowy
shape of a boxer and began to attack
d11424 the mass of spiders conducted
itself at the level of a professional
boxer dodging d11424's hits before
coming back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut it before he
could defend himself
d11424 fell to the ground unconscious
and guards were forced to interrupt the
test in order to remove him from the
room and take him to the infirmary for
medical treatment after taking some time
to recuperate
d11424 returned to testing with
scp-3247-a it was instructed to mime
steering a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerged
from
scp-3247 arranging themselves into the
shape of a sedan
d11424 was then commanded to climb
inside of the spider car and see if he
could start it he refused insisting I'm
not getting in a spider car are you nuts
when pressed by control to comply with
orders he made a rude hand gesture I'll
let you guess what that was the spiders
began to scramble to reassemble
themselves in response to the changed
gesture prompting control to stop the
test early to spare the researchers
sensibilities with strict guidelines to
avoid inappropriate or violent gestures
d11424 was sent back into the testing
chamber with instruction to try out a
variety of animal inspired gestures in
Rapid succession he formed one hand into
a fist and made a peace sign with the
other hand putting them together to make
a snail as he made his hand snail crawl
through the air the spiders crawled onto
the floor and assembled into the shape
of a snail in front of d11424 though the
spiders moved quickly at their usual
scuttling Pace once they formed into the
snail they slowed to a gradual creep
d11424 noted a shiny slimy Trail left
behind on the floor as the spider snail
moved he was asked to consider touching
it but refused simply stating ew no next
he took his hands and formed the shape
of a wolf's head howling at the moon the
research staff were curious to see if
the spiders would form a wolf's head or
the animal's entire body they got their
answer as the spider swarmed and shifted
forming the shape of a full-sized gray
wolf the wolf padded back and forth
across the room before sitting down
lifting its head and emitting an audible
howl that sounded almost
indistinguishable from the real thing
next d11424 crossed his thumbs over each
other fluttering hands like a pair of
wings the spider separated into smaller
groups and came together to form
butterflies similar in size to a monarch
these spider butterflies began to flap
their wings and much to d11424 surprise
they took flight and swirled through the
air around him the d-class was so moved
by the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture d-11424 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled away returning to
scp-3247 and the remaining spiders took
on the form of a rabbit the spider
rabbit hopped realistically around the
room twitching its ears and tail at this
point d11424 was instructed to offer the
spider rabbit a carrot he produced a
carrot from his pocket holding it out in
front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d11424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go
scp-3247 is kept in an isolated chamber
located in the arachnid wing of area 12.
it does not appear to require food or
rest but it has been provided with a
television and a collection of silent
films for morale purposes instances of
scp-3247-a are fed via a fully automated
system that dispenses 20 grams of live
crickets every week should a Containment
Breach occur staff have been instructed
to find a way to make escaped spiders
take on the shape that renders them
motionless then simply pick the spider
class stir up and place it back inside
of the cell it is unlikely that the
foundation will ever get an explanation
for where the intangible mime and his
merry band of spider performers
originated from but one thing is clear
they won't be performing in public again
anytime soon now check out scp-058 Heart
of Darkness and
scp-2427 a thing full of stuff